it's like watching the modern day Comics
though it's like there's more punch
lines and there's it's more in modern
day comedy I think they let things
breathe I thought more back there's a
lot of TED Talks happening right now
we come from punchline area there's a
lot of TED Talks going on yeah
anyway Ted Talk just
a thing behind them
punchline yeah
no get to a [__]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah but and I'm a comedian and you
are too so I have every right to talk
[__] about this art form now I just
think you know get to a punch line it's
like a sport you know you gotta You
Gotta Throw strikes I'm gonna [__] what
your style is you gotta hit the strike
zone it doesn't matter if you throw up
this way no matter if you pitch under
you gotta hit us the same for comedy but
some of the powers that be going you
know it doesn't have to be funny
and we're gonna give them a special with
no funny
yeah the [__] out of here yeah like when
I watched when I watched Bill Burr when
I watched the guys that and the women
that do I go yeah that's comedy that's
all you to do but there's a lot of TED
Talks going on I'm sorry yeah I know a
lot I don't say everybody but there's a
lot of TED Talks I have the same
feelings as you bro but I try to keep it
down you don't like to talk about
anything
you're like this no no remember I know
because I get in trouble why do you get
in trouble because I start talking [__]
about people and this and that and then
I get into it very Asian thing what to
be quiet no no you guys are the good
race no no no no you're the you're the
I'm like that you're the Sweden of races
guys no no you're neutral no I used to
be you don't want to cause no trouble I
don't want no trouble yeah but once I
don't want to lose
money
I was gonna play the mailman I don't
want to lose that yeah we went in a
different direction Bobby Lee I've said
some crazy [__] and I just you know
instead of you said about people well
don't be specific man
yeah oh that's what it is I talked in
general just this [__] [__] that
[__] you can suck my dick yeah
yeah no you're interested just speak in
general it's not about hating I just go
there's a lot of TED Talks happening
yeah and as a person who actually does
comedy I go wow where's the punch slice
you get to just do that I'm afraid to
bomb I don't wanna these [__]
come up with confidence bombing that's
like a new art form so uh hey good yeah
no laughs
[__] that I'm like I hope this is you
you know how paranoid you get you're
like
I don't I don't have 20 minutes
and you did
yeah yeah yeah back in the day but that
was a good paranoia because it's like
it's the respect for the art form we
gotta come with it yeah I want that fear
no it's like a sport I better score
points tonight yeah are you gonna get
booed we need to bring that back
get the [__] up
get that [__] out of here we need
that we need audiences we need booing
back yeah
there used to be show time at the Apollo
yeah and they'd be like oh hell no yeah
the [__] off we need that we gotta bring
back Tomatoes oh tomatoes and eggs
tomatoes and eggs
bullying [__] that God think Godfrey the
hook oh my God
you know
Asia what gong the [__] a Gong Banger
gone damn it oh you know T-Rex
we need the gong again that was uh what
was his name
what was his name Gong Show no no no no
no
what was it what was what was his name
the host of uh Chuck Barris
the guitarist no not Chuck Barris Chuck
Barris yeah there's Paris he's like he
was an FBI agent they're saying he's
from FBI [__] a lot of [__] with that
guy but Chuck Barris was gong show when
you stunk it was like
I we we need that I'm talking about when
it's reasonable not just booing for
Bowie's sake but when they really stick
you go
[__] out of here man they're trying new
jokes that's one thing that's that's one
thing and that should be you should let
them know yeah it's fine but I'm talking
about on a regular Saturday night
Saturday night Saturday night or Laugh
Factory or whatever whatever boom do
your [__] right he's like bomb so you
know boo yeah [__] out of here we didn't
like that [__] yeah but don't you think
it's harder now to get get to become a
regular at the seller get a Saturday
night spot you have to bring it to get a
Saturday night
um at the salary the SD shout out to SD
I love Theodore who's been booking that
place since the 80s yeah she's from
Israel estia Durham and I like when I'll
I'll like suggest a comedian to her I
say Este because I have to call her she
doesn't like when you put her on the Spy
go Esty what do you think about this
community she goes Godfrey I like funny
the laughs have to be here here yeah
it's it's too much of a space I need
funny I need and I like that though yeah
some of the to try a TED Talk At The
Cellar you can't what and these and it's
such an international crowd they'll be
like and everyone Focus from whatever
Saudi be like what did the guys this guy
is garbage what's why is he here I love
that because I love that coffee too much
of God was there and she put me um gave
me five spots over the weekend and she
put me next to me when David passed you
were in New York oh yeah I was in New
York and she put me after yamanika every
show oh my God right and I knew when I
was in the [__] Cellar and yamanika
was killing right I went oh I know what
this is yeah and I have to hit that and
you did it and I did it and they said
you were funny as [__] yeah yeah and so
I know you know I mean I know how to do
it you do I know what it is but what I'm
saying is that but to get to that point
on a Saturday night to get stamped and
then there's a band yeah that's right
you're like [__] because there's a band
in her dope I love the pressure and and
the pressure's like everything someone's
killing give it up and already was
already yeah oh God he's always there so
Artie has energy he's like ladies and
gentlemen yeah
yeah oh you're not gonna do that room
you're not gonna and I like that I like
it because I believe and I came here you
can fly I came from yes
I believe I can touch the sky Ricochet
Ricochet [__] juice
cause you know they get loose
okay I love it so
I believe I come from the sports era
yeah Sports you know when I played
Sports you know baseball football you
know I did all that [__] and when you
stunk you sat on the bench
I remember missing two I mean ground
balls I [__] up two ground balls I was
shortstop two ground balls bomb hit hit
my butt but and my coach was like the
[__] on a bad show what the [__] are you
doing two scores right [__] that type of
[__] slam the hat and I deserved it sat
down I [__] up you know we need that
in this business God stunk a Godfrey you
not going up I don't give a [__] who
your father is Godfrey look at me okay
what they would say though is about us
they're not being real right who these
guys that don't rely on punch lines you
know I mean you know we you know we're
like you know um going deeper right and
we're we have a message and we have a
point of view and go get a Podium then
okay go get a podium
go on sabbatical go get a Podium and do
speeches be in that category of speech
making but I could do the same [__] I
could rant about [__] yeah but I want
punch lines in between like like Bobby
I think when I'm talking about white
people
see yeah you know I go on my rents but I
got punch lines in between I can do a
clan joke but there's punch lines and
even the audience the white members of
the audience and they're like that [__]
was funny because they're there for
comedy yeah it doesn't matter what your
message is they they're the laugh of
regardless there's nothing wrong it's
easy to be profound if you ain't got no
punch lines you know what I mean that's
easy like listen you don't understand
that the economy okay where's the
[__] punch line it's like Jon Stewart
who's one of the dopest Comics you're so
good he gets that [__] and he's
so politically oh sound yeah and he
buries uh politicians but he's [__]
funny yes he boom he hits a he hits a
certain thing he says something really
hard but bomb there's another punch line
but you know the problem with Jon
Stewart this new show he'll say some
really [__] deep political of a bomb
there's a [__] punch line that is
what I'm talking about it you can't be
too preachy because they come to see
comedy really so whatever these people
that are not funnier it's not funny
they're just not [__] you're gonna
tell me Brian Regan was doing it wrong
Carlin did it wrong Pryor did it wrong
Joan Rivers did it wrong you're gonna
tell me all these Sam Kinston did it
wrong go [__] yourself yeah that's the
way you're supposed to do comedy punch
lines tags [__] you that's it plain and
simple